it's another week and that means it's
time for new releases if you haven't
noticed by now I'm not married but don't
worry she'll be back next week where is
Mary you ask well she's neck deep in
Mirror's Edge catalyst and preparing for
e3 but speaking of Mirror's Edge
catalyst that game comes out this week
step into the shoes of faith a gutsy
park forest as she attempts to overthrow
totalitarian government your playground
a futuristic city called glass spoilers
there's lots of glass like seriously
this town is almost only glass catalyst
is a reboot / prequel of 2008 smears
edge this time you'll have an open world
to explore filled with races time trials
and people to knock the [ __ ] out of you
can take a leap of faith on jun 7 but
maybe you want a platformer you can take
with you on the go lucky for you kirby
planet robobot comes out the 10 the pink
puffball returns and as you expect he's
got an appetite for destruction as
always you can swallow foes and steal
their powers but if your enemies aren't
threatened by that pink puffball you can
hop into a suit of robot armor and bash
drive and fly your way through a new
mechanized world that comes the 3ds on
jun 10 and guess what we've already got
a review up for it turns out we actually
liked it quite a bit how about a remake
odin sphere leaf tracer comes out on
playstation 4 PlayStation 3 and Vita on
the 7th odin sphere spans five
interconnected stories about the warring
nations of eerie on leaf there are seers
and 2d action RPG where characters are
armed with a weapon called a cipher
apart from combat players can combine
items using alchemy and cook by finding
recipes and ingredients throughout the
world odin sphere leaf drosera comes out
the seventh and for more information on
that check out our review this week
you'll also be able to explore the
streets of London as one of the most
famous detectives of all time Sherlock
Holmes the devil's daughter comes to
playstation 4 xbox one and pc on the
10th the stakes are even higher this
time and homes will have to put
everything at risk if he wants to get to
the bottom of this investigation the
devil's daughter features updated
characters new puzzles and a darker
story join Sherlock and Watson on
10th if it's Sherlock Holmes mystery
isn't enough for you how about a
Minecraft mystery episode 6 of minecraft
story mode comes out this week and it's
called a portal to mystery you can pick
this up on pc playstation 3 playstation
4 xbox 360 xbox one playstation vita and
iOS there will also be death haunted
mansions pumpkins and popular youtubers
that I'm probably too old to recognize
Halloween comes early this year on june
seven that's all i have for you this
week but hopefully between Mirror's Edge
catalysts and Kirby planet robobot
you'll have plenty to keep you busy and
before I go remember that these dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change we'll see you next
week